uh it's very interesting that you
mentioned you know you didn't want to go
to janae and ask
uh you know is there a role for me
because you've made no secrets about
wanting to play bain
this story came out came out recently
and it's very interesting to me because
i
i think i feel like the more we have
these established universes the more we
have
these stories of people going to the
studio on being like i want to play this
role i'm just wondering
sort of what what was the moment for you
where we're like i
i'm the person i should be playing was
it was
a connection with the character was that
uh just a yeah there was something about
you know there's certain characters that
i've uh
i don't know i've just kind of latched
on to over the past
10 20 years and bain was one of them and
not like not
like not like no discredit to like tom
hardy's version of bane
i love i loved his performance i love
that film but i just feel like uh you
know i'd love
i love a crack at it i think i could
bring an interesting twist to it and i
think i could do the character justice
justice uh not only um and performance
but also on physicality like i'd love
that role where i just had to
you know sit down and go back up to like
320 pounds just to portray this
character like i would like
that i would happen um but i just feel
like i could do this character justice
and bring
you know really bring like a strong uh
performance to him as well and play bain
in a way
you know that's not only menacing and
ominous but also like freakishly
intelligent you know and just terrifying
in
in that manner and also like i i think
that bane would be the type of character
that's so menacing and so terrifying
um and so intelligent that he would
hardly ever raise his voice
you know i think he would almost be like
a like mr
the character i played in bond mr hinks
was so terrifying
his demeanor hardly ever changed
actually he was very happy to be beating
the hell out of someone he was
and i think that's the way i think
that's the way i perceive bane to be as
well
because he's not only he would be
physically superior but he would also be
mentally superior and i i just love that
i love the idea of that the challenge of
playing that character because
i like i like when you can play a brute
who's not your
you know your predictable brute he's a
brute that
he doesn't need to raise his voice
because anybody any big muscular guy can
play that guy who's screaming
and and growling and you know but if you
play a guy who's
not only physically menacing but is
soft-spoking
soft-spoken and just as terrifying even
more terrifying
when he's speaking to you softly with a
smile on his face
then that is a villain that's a villain
i want to play you know so that
that's kind of like the way i see bane
in that and i did i
i don't make any pretense about it i so
i had a chance to get him you know a
meeting at wb and i walked in and i
they were talking to me about this and
that and i said hey let's talk about
let's talk about bain
[Laughter]
you know that happened to me one other
time in my career and i had a meeting at
universal
and they wanted to talk to me about fast
and furious and i said i'm i'm not
interested let's talk about marcus
phoenix
you know and so what's the connection to
that
did they sort of go i think they were uh
little put off but you know it's like
man you
you get a shot i don't mean to offend
anybody i'm not putting down anything
else i'm just saying
like this is way more interesting to me
i don't want to you know pretend like
i'm actually interested in something i'm
not
when i see when there's something i'm
actually really excited about that you
guys you know you guys have under
control
like would you consider me for that i
mean i don't think there's any harm in
that i'm not trying to be
step on anybody else tell anybody else's
toes or disrespect anybody else i'm just
saying like this is what i love man i'm
i'm seriously passionate about this like
i do a good job for you guys on this
so i don't think there's anything wrong
with that and so but twice in my career
that happened and
twice in my career didn't pan out not
yet
not yet still if i had given the
opportunity
again i would just you know i don't see
any harm in
chasing your dreams or being honest with
someone and saying man this is what i
really am passionate about
you know if you guys would consider me
for this i'd really you know i'd do this
justice you know i think when people are
more personally invested it's just going
to be a better product